so data is an ocean on the Azim the
philosopher is 360 meters long she put
out from China in mid-december captain
Duke waters doff heads out to meet her
in his tugboat bulldog via 14 le it's
around 9 a.m. on the Elbe estuary near
Hamburg the container ship can carry
almost 150,000 metric tons that's the
reason for the escorting the port
requires that if it were to yaw to far
it could block the entire Elbe River and
traffic would stop until they've pulled
it out again three kilometers closer
into the port the container ship has to
go on a tow-rope
several tugboats work together to tow it
into the harbor Basin
the skipper's have to coordinate every
move Hamburg is Germany's biggest and
principal port and Europe's second
largest it's been growing and developing
for centuries
today some nine million containers move
through it annually
as if it's faked when it branches out
everywhere you have lots of individual
harbors on duty to you and then you've
got the tides running at various rates
it's not an easy port to work in it's
pretty complicated completed it'll take
them at least another hour to maneuver
the selasa abra through the ebb and flow
and the currents to its birth
it's noontime and the container ship
must be maneuvered into the Inner Harbor
along with colleagues on another tugboat
captain boaters Dolph pushes the huge
vessel towards the Cay wall at least one
mega ship like this docks in Hamburg
each day one in every three containers
is either coming from or bound for China
but big vessels can only enter the
harbor half-full otherwise they'd sit
too deep for the Elbe it's a major
drawback the port of Hamburg wants to
deepen the Elbe but a lot of people are
against it there's a big battle about
deepening it so that ships with a
draught of 14 meters can come in here
fully loaded at 2 p.m. the tug takes a
break entries must be made into the
ship's logbook which route did the
tugboat take when was it last refueled
did anything unusual occur today
everything went smoothly this sailors
been grocery shopping the crew who live
and work aboard the tugboat for two
weeks at a time before they return to
pushing and pulling other vessels the
mechanic must check both engines the
driving force behind the tug the engines
have a combined output of 5,600
horsepower
quite a bit for a tug of this size there
are chunks which produce around 7,000
horsepower but this is one of the big
boys and it's not long before the tug
services are needed again shipping
companies pay between two and four
thousand euros per tow it's money
well-spent for a ship and its cargo to
dock safely
late afternoon on the bridge of the
Bulldog the tugboats crew is hard at
work the grande Tama won't be the last
of today's customers business is picked
up at Hamburg Harbor since it imploded
back in 2009 but in shipping the price
per container is falling profit margins
have grown razor thin for shipping
companies that's why the ships they're
building are growing larger and larger
to take on as much freight as possible
but at the same time keep costs steady
the freighter has to be completely
offloaded within 48 hours delay has
caused money the Bulldog leaves the
harbor heading for the company's docks
time for the crew members to grab a bite
to eat they say working on a tugboat
demands flexibility this evening for
example they have no idea when their
services will be needed the pilot said
next one's due to arrive at 9:00 p.m.
but another ship could need a tug before
that then they'll give us a call and
we'll have to head out so you're on
standby yep 14 days in a row only then
will the crew have two weeks off and
time for dinner with their families